We have the phrase 17 whole and 4/9
minus 12 whole and 2/3.
I recommend that you stop the video
and try to solve it yourself.
Let's examine it.
What I will do is write
these mixed numbers in another way.
I will write this as a 17 whole and 4/9
minus 12 whole and 2/3.
I will write 12 exactly under 17,
and 2/3 under 4/9.
Let's make it quite clear that we're getting 12 whole and 2/3
from 17 and 4/9.
The first thing we want to do,
is to look at the fragments
and start subtracting from them,
but see, they have different denominators.
We have 9 and 3.
Then the first thing we want to do,
is to get a common denominator,
and the good common denominator will be the smallest number,
which is shared at 9 and 3 at the same time.
What is this number?
To find him,
I prefer to start with the bigger number, 9.
I say: is it divided into 3?
Well yes, divide by 3.
Share the other denominator,
so that's actually the smallest common fold.
If it was not, I would continue to look for larger numbers,
which are multiples of 9.
I was going to try with 18, then with 27,
and continue until I find a number,
which is divided into 3.
But I did not have to do it,
because 9 is divided into 3.
I can write these fragments
with denominator 9.
The top is recorded with a denominator 9,
so I can transcribe it.
17 whole and 4/9.
And the lower number can be written as 12
and some number on 9.
How many nine are 2/3?
To receive ninth from third,
I have to multiply by 3, so I multiply by 3,
but I have to multiply the numerator too.
2 by 3 is 6.
2/3 is equal to 6/9.
Now I can try to pull them out.
Even here when I try to pull out,
I get a bigger liver,
which I try to pull out of a smaller one.
I have 4/9 minus 6/9.
What can I do?
The answer is that I can regroup.
I can take a whole of 17.
Let me do it.
If I take one unit of 17,
it will become 16,
and this unit I just took,
you can say that this is the place of the integer,
I can add it to this liver.
One unit will be 9/9.
I just regrouped.
I took 9/9 from 17.
9/9 is 1 and when I take 9/9 out of 17, I'm left with 16,
then regroup them and add that
in the place of the fractures - you can accept it and so.
How much is 4/9 plus 9/9?
This will be equal to 13/9.
This is here 13/9.
13/9.
It's a strange way to record it, but 17 whole and 4/9
is the same as 16 whole and 13/9, because, pay attention,
that it is bigger than the other one.
This is the same as 1 whole and 4/9.
1 and 4/9 plus 16 will be 17 and 4/9.
Why did I do all this?
13/9 is greater than 6/9, so I can get them out.
How much is 13/9 minus 6/9?
13 of something, in this case 9
minus 6 of the same thing will be equal to 7/9.
7, I will write it in neutral color.
This will be equal to 7/9.
13/9 minus 6/9 is 7/9.
Then I can look at the whole parts.
Here I am 16.
16 minus 12 is 4, and ready.
17 whole and 4/9 minus 12 and 2/3
is equal to 4 and 7/9.